comment vas y tu as très bien j'aime
bien ça va bien pas abuser mais il ya eu
plus de peur que de mal c'est ça
d'accord voilà elle en bonne santé alors
là qu'est ce qui s'est passé ben tout
simplement la première victime qui a été
blessé par le chien si une jeune fille
de 40 ans est encore celle de 15 en inde
dont quinze ans rue est en train de
promener le chien oui avec un ami à elle
il est acquis ce chien
ça c'est la principale question c'est
pas écrit ce chien s'en fait d'après ce
que j'ai compris de ce qu'on m'a
expliqué la personne ne voulait plus de
ce chien et il voulait s'en débarrasser
donc il donnait à qui voulait la voix on
a relancé la personne à qui est le chien
je ne pense pas que je pense pas je
pense pas qu'il va se montrer tout de
suite d'accord mais en gros la paix la
jeune fille est en train de promener le
chien et je sais pas dans un mouvement
d'excitation quoi s'est mis à courir
avec le chien mais le chien a mal réagi
c'est à dire que quand la jeune fille a
couru je ne sais pas pourquoi parce qu
il a réagi et l'a mordu mais sauf que
quand le chien l'a mordu et c'est là où
vous vous trompez tous puisque même eu
hier mathieu dix aidé des âneries en
disant que la police est arrivée à ont
dû géant cinq secondes mais c'est pas
vrai le chien a agressé la jeune fille
et c'est des jeunes habitants du
quartier qui sont venus et qui ont
enlevé le chien de la fis donc encore
une fois la preuve qu' il n'y avait pas
que la seule solution n'était pas que de
le tuer c'est la première grève ça c'est
la première agression des jeunes qu'on
appelait la police la police et les
pompiers et les jeunes ont rattrapé le
chien l'ont attaché que l'on attaché à
un poteau la police et les pompiers sont
arrivés sur les lieux de la faire et ont
demandé ce qui s'était passé et cetera
mais maintenant il ya eu une sorte de
cohue parce que plusieurs personnes
parler et c est à ce moment là la police
ça je peux pas vous dire pour quelle
raison mais ont décidé de d'embarquer
une personne donc ça a créé des
échauffourées le chien qui était attaché
d'un d'un autre côté qui était surveillé
par une dame
voilà justement cette dame est cette
dame attention c'est elle qui est venue
pour défendre le chien de base la dame
est venue pour défendre le chien en
disant qu'elle connaissait et au final
pendant quelques échauffourées des
policiers à gauche comme on le voit est
belle le chien forcément qui était déjà
énervé étendue et apparemment plutôt
instable a voulu a voulu réagir et
attaquer la femme a essayé de le
maîtriser et de l'amendé et il a mordu
et c'est là que le deuxième policier
enfin qu'on voit le policier arrivé
d'ailleurs que les policiers étaient
dehors puisque la police là bas à gauche
on les voit il ne s'occupe même pas du
chien qui en train d'attaquer la dame
ils sont en train d'essayer d'arrêter
quelqu'un que je ne sais pas ce qu'il a
fait mais là c'est une autre équipe de
la police qui intervient qui défend la
dent maintenant moi ça me déchire le
coeur de voir une image comme ça parce
que moi j'ai un chien et on tue aussi
staff oui j'ai un chien c'est vrai que
c'est assez difficile mais on se dit on
se dit on il faut protéger la dame c'est
ça en aucun cas je pense que le policier
il s'est dit c'est le verra demain je
vais tuer un chien ça c'est l'impossible
il a réagi parce qu'il a vu une
situation d'urgence qu'on a très peur
pour l'ablation
si la crap à la gorge ou qu ils bien sûr
tu es bien suivez bien sûr que là tu es
bien sûr la deuxième dame va bien aussi
mais elles étaient même moins mordu que
l'adolescente avait hier ce que je
comprends pas c'est pourquoi la police
ils ont été appelés parce que le chien
mort d'une adolescente pourquoi ils ne
sont pas tout de suite occupé du chien
non parce qu'en fait et ils nous l'ont
dit il ya un problème avec un liner
sonne la bassure il cessa lisez donc
vous mais voilà en soit en fait le vrai
le vrai souci c
c'était ce qu'on pouvait faire autrement
lorsque le chien a été abattu et même
vous qui était qui est proche de deux
affaires vous dites pierre on voit pas
tellement comment il aurait pu faire
vraiment de solution massim émission
sept jeunes ont réussi à l'enlever de la
jeune fille c'est la police nationale ne
peut pas le faire mais oui mais là là le
problème c'est qu'ils disent est attaqué
sur un peu de temps il a été attaqué une
fois oui c'est compliqué et puis je vous
dire ça me fait de la peine pour chien
mais quoi qu'il arrive je pense que ce
chien ont été piqués
sais même pas qui est son maître le
problème que diam's c'est pas le chien
c'est le mestre c'est pas bien sûr que
ça tout temps et puis elle a commencé la
mairie il ya des vraies règles j'en ai
un j'ai eu un problème il ya trois jours
il ya des prairies il faut aller en
mairie lady gaga a révélé qu'il faut
faire un stage c'est bien sécurisé un ou
deux et le problème d'ailleurs si le
propriétaire ne trouve pas c'est
peut-être à cause de ça parce qu'il n'a
pas fait les démarches nécessaires et
obligatoires cpo ça la réalité alors
hier et hier guillaume disait un truc
qui disait la vie d'une enfant vaut
celle d'un chien ça a été énormément
commentée sur les réseaux est ce que
pour vous guillaume a été trop loin ou
pas est ce que vous trouvez que c'est
été
témoins d'un pont non c'est impossible
de dire ça j'adore les animaux j'ai eu
des chiens etc guillaume je t'aime
beaucoup mais tu sais ce que tu as dit
hier c'est une énorme connerie c'est
demain matin ton chien qui est un chien
d'ailleurs un peu particulier d'après
toi s'attaque à mon fils de 18 mois qui
lui arrache la gorge je te jure que
c'est vrai qu'une réaction soit je le
tue - le chien se le faire piquer avec
avec aucun scrupule la vie d'un enfant
ne vaut pas la vie d'un chien jeu désolé
le monde descendent alors il y en a qui
pensent ça il ya des gens qui sont qu'il
dise que tout les toutes les vies
humaines voile espéces tout est vu man
va nullement eh ben pour moi excuse moi
non alors iris nous et qu'on vous avez
vu ces images peut-être porte parole de
l'ap et a pris des hoba bavard est bon
qu'est-ce que vous êtes dit est ce que
pour vous on aurait pu faire autrement
il existe deux méthodes évidemment pour
arrêter une session mordant ont déjà
dans le cadre d'une d'une session
d'éducation auprès du chien là c'est le
chaos total on voit que tout le monde
est hyper agressif il père angoissé le
chien réagit comme tout le monde en fait
après j'entends bien que c'est très
compliqué d'arrêter
la façon dont le chien s'est accroché on
peut faire un cri strident on peut faire
un coup de sifflet on y lit à des
méthodes après est ce que les policiers
sont formés à ce alors ils nous l'ont
dit hier les poyas ils ont essayé de
bien des voix là y'avait pas toi tu
seras le chien mais il n'avait pas de
voiture pour venir même temps c'est
incroyable c'est en dessous des
effectifs donc ce ne sont pas des
spécialistes qui sont venus oui et on y
dans ce cas là ils ont appelé la brigade
spécialisée qui aurait pu faire
peut-être
différemment mais eux en fait ils n'ont
pas pu les faire venir puisqu'il n'est
pas de deux véhicules et ils ont fait
comme comme ils ont sont noyées sur le
baiser personnes ils ont essayé de
sauver la vieille dame j'entends bien là
ce qui est important de considérer c'est
que c'est pas une question celle qui a
été soulevée de la valeur de la vie d'un
être vivant conscient par rapport à
celle d'un être vivant conscient c'est
pas une question à laquelle on répond à
la légère c'est pas une question à
laquelle on répond de façon arbitraire
faut vraiment entendre que là la
situation elle est chaotique mais si ça
avait été votre chien avec une personne
que vous détestez ou si c'est un shack
vous connaissez pas avec une personne
que vous adorez la réponse n'est pas la
même non
mais moi j'ai un chien et j'ai un chien
qui gelé d'hier est un peu compliquée ce
que j'ai pris à la spa et qui donc a une
histoire un peu chaotique et qui a du
mal avec ses congénères pas du tout avec
les humains avec les enfants ça se passe
très bien et c'est en revanche pour le
promener c'est compliqué parce que dès
qu'il ya un chien même à 200 m il est
dans tous ses états mais pour autant je
hais je suis navré de le dire mais si
malheureusement il venait à s'attaquer à
quelqu'un est il quand même vous même la
personne que je déteste le plus au monde
et d'un jeu je préfère que cette
personne reste en vie que mon chien je
suis moi moi j'aime j'aime le dire
j'aime le discours des gens qui est très
modérée et intelligemment bien sûr il
sait bien que surtout il s'agit pas de
rabaisser la valeur de la vie d'un être
humain absolument pas ça n'a jamais été
ça c'est de considérer que le chien
n'est pas un objet non ça c'est vivre
dont on peut abréger à la vie comme
comme on le veut par moments ça notre
société tout entière devrait se poser
cette question on considère les chiens
aujourd'hui en france et encore
énormément qui peuvent les troquer les
vendre les acheter comme un objet sur
leboncoin sur internet n'importe où
c'est ça la vraie question guillaume
hier a eu des mots extrêmement repris
partout sur les réseaux vous vous êtes
choqué aussi béatrice parce qu a dit
guillaume ouais je suis choqué je pense
qu'aussi peu d'espèces qui n'a pas
d'enfant moi j'adore les chiens j'ai
toujours j'ai eu un rottweiler j'ai eu
un labrador chihuahua dont j'adore
passionnément les chiens mais
effectivement entre la vie d'un enfant
ou d'une personne et la vie d'un animal
malheureusement est la question que je
pose c'est où on s'arrête parce que si
c'est valable pour un chien que la vie
d'un chien vaut la vie d'un d'une
personne dans ses créations nées dans la
jungle on se fait attaquer je sais pas
par un crocodile un serpent est ce que
c'est la même chose s km hiérarchie dont
les animaux mouse à mal notre concept
voilà cinq ans non mais attends à quel
mac à un insecte pas je veux dire où on
allait de la vie samse multiforme moi je
respecte toute la ville mais dans une a4
d'urgence en fait nous on arrête ce
jugement-là guillaume quesque tu réponds
déjà lors déjà vous êtes extrêmement mal
à l'aise puisque vous vous déformer mes
propos vous entendez que j'ai dit qu'il
valait mieux qu'un enfant meurt 15
charmeur j'ai dit qu'un chien gernelle
avellin avant dotée d'une sensibilité et
à ne fallait pas traité comme rien aidé
dire que sa vie ne vaut rien première
chose deuxième chose je trouve qu'on ne
s'arrête pas et c'est sur le témoignage
de monsieur qui a bien montré la manière
dont intérêts dont on réagir à
l'information aujourd'hui on a une vidéo
de 20 secondes sortie de son contexte
pixelisé on voit rien on sait pas ce qui
s'est passé avant on sait pas ce qui
s'est passé après hier vous étiez tous
dans l'émotion à dire mais vous rendez
compte il est en train de mourir c'est
atroce qu'est ce que vous en savez qu
elle en train de mourir et manque de bol
pour vous monsieur vous a quand même dit
on s'est pas arrêtée dessus mais
qu'apparemment le chien n'était pas si
dangereux que ça puisqu'il ya des
personnes qui ont réussi à l'extraire
une première fois donc première chose et
je répète mes propos oui la vie d'un
chien ne vaut pas rien et vous dites ça
en fait vous répéter bêtement un truc
qu'on nous a dit dans notre éducation à
tous oui la vie de l'homme vaut mieux
que celle des autres êtres vivants mais
pourquoi en fait pourquoi on devrait
tuer un chien parce qu'ils paient ce
qu'ils dérapent une fois il ya des
milliers des gens dont c'est le métier
ça s'appelle les éducateurs canins de
rééduquer les chiens ayant des
comportements problématiques pour
justement qu'il ne soit pas eu canadie
daniel faut pas banaliser la mort des
chandelles juillet comme sagna il
confirme complètement fou ça c'est de la
pollution
c'est de la réflexion là on est dans une
urgence moi je je vois des images
violentes mais je vois un sauvetage
parce qu est-ce qu on ne sait pas ce qui
aurait pu se passer si le chien n'avait
pas là s'est lâché on l'a dit hier donc
certes complètement et dick et moi je
vais même au delà du chien imagine que
tu es quelqu'un agresse une jeune femme
il est vraiment en train de la tuer
c'est lui l'agresseur est ce que s'il
est si tu as une arme tu tires sur qui
tu tirais forcément sur l'agresseur donc
on n'est même plus dans le chien ou pas
le chien c'est lui l'agresseur et
nicolas des palaces canigou d'un
sauvetage est ce qu a dit guillaume moi
j'ai eu un problème avec mon american
staff ya trois jours quand la famille
qui m'a fait les piquets
l'american staff n'est pas rée chirac au
20 août c'est la première chose je
nageais spécifique extrêmement puissant
et même quand il joue il peut être
dangereux je suis d'accord il n'a qu'un
m il faut apprendre de cette race si on
veut un american staff
le problème aujourd'hui c'est qu'on est
en train de tout mélanger cercle il ya
trois jours mon chien est sorti par
mégarde à manger un autre chien et le
premier truc le premier danger que
j'avais risque que j'avais c'est que la
police vienne et le pic sans explication
donc à un moment donné c'est aussi aux
chiens d'avoir sept jours d'avoir cette
responsabilité quand on prend un chien
comme un american staff ce n'est pas un
chien comme un autre mais c'est un des
meilleurs chiens qui existe sur mer mais
après on ne compare pas les deux parce
que là on était dans l'urgence donc à un
moment donné on a répondu un premier
type d'urgence avec la police mais voit
american staff et le premier truc qui
fait comme tous les gens dans la rue
c'est y voient un danger bavoil
américaine stable et un chien mais nico
se promettent un héros ton émotions de
travail tu vois bien que rim est de tuer
un chien je parle d'un chien que je
connais la voile a acheté barda mois ci
s'est nourrie vient après aujourd'hui
les american staff en train de les
mélanger les uns avec les autres il ya
beaucoup de gens des cités qui s'occupe
ces chiens sans savoir ce qu'il faut en
faire et là le problème c'est que ce
chien ne peut pas être seul dans une
cité ou dans la rue on ne peut pas
laisser
mandali qui s'est passé il a eu peur il
a sauté sur le truc mais tu ne peux pas
faire autre chose et tu ne peux pas
comparer bien sûr la vie d'êtres humains
à la vie d'un chien là en l'occurrence
il fallait tuer ce chien parce que on
sait pas d'où il vient on ne sait pas si
les vaccinés on sait pas si la russe qui
l'a pas la rage on sait pas où est le
maître qui peut répondre tout de suite
en l'occurrence moi quand j'ai vu le
médecin jour on m'a appelé j'ai répondu
tout de suite pour le carnet de santé
pour le fait qu'ils avaient été déclarés
à la mairie pour le fait que c'est un
chien qui ne risque rien donc à un
moment donné je suis désolé une icône
art ça vous fait marrer parce que c'est
bon ça n'était pas évident ça te fait
m'a réglée quand il pleure il me fait
marrer mais non mais en vrai nom mais je
suis méfiant il est touché par ce sont
des chiens de garde et nicolas n'étant
que ton chien n'est pas été euthanasiés
en vrai comment c'est touchant ce que la
nature contentons chien n'est pas élu
parce qu'il est venu et il est devenu
dingue et comme ils ont une puissance
monstrueuse auriez une dame qui a sauté
qui a sauté près de son chien il s'est
passé des choix l'anfac j'ai pu le
garder en vie moi là je suis d'accord en
réalité j'aurais pas pu le garder en moi
là où je suis d'accord avec eux et avec
nicolas et pour le coup pas trop aidé le
film c'est que ces chiens là même s'ils
sont tous très gentils faut pas dire que
c'est des chiens méchants ne sont pas
méchants mais ce ne sont pas des chiens
comme les autres moi j'ai d'autres
chiens des chiens plus classique des
golden retriever etc oui ce sont des
changes et des réactions un peu
surprenant dit oui mais là et donc il
faut s'en occuper correctement s'agit
vrd vous provenant à la vidéo merci
voilà merci je lui les heures passent
plus ceux qui répondent oui apparaissent
totalement déconnectés de la réalité ou
déconnecté et bravo monsieur et bravo
grippe a c'est pas tout à fait ce qu'a
dit pierre ainsi il a dit il a dit après
il a dit après sur l'île a dit sceptique
savais pas trop où il n'y avait pas de
danger
survivants donc j'aime regarder les
images
laissez moi
finir sa chérie maîtrise alaoui les cgu
qu'une il n'y a pas de danger il n'y a
pas de petites filles de chien est
attaché les policiers sont paniqués ils
tirent cette fois ils auraient pu le taz
et il n'y avait pas nécessité ne tuer le
chien et quand guillaume a prononcé sa
phrase et deux fois je le soutiens c'est
une symbolique il va dire qu une vie de
chien là auraient pu être sauvées voilà
on aurait pu sauver seul
voilà autant expliqué hier deux
policiers a expliqué hier qu'ils aient
qu'il avait un taser et qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas tellement chaque année à
tana mais je connais les tasers ils en
avaient chacun valérie
anciens comme ça ça une tonne de
pression des pressions sur dix victoires
et aux hurricanes une prime de crise il
était attaché le chien
mais regarde nicolas il connaît pas un
problème
de puissance ce chien est joué c'est un
déchirement puissant et tu ne peux rien
faire
j'ai
dessiné sur toi que tu racontes il n'est
pas sûr et efficace et je vais et excité
là comme ça pendant pendant des heures
et des heures on va voir ce que tu vas
devenir alors là c'est déjà
la dame se fait égorger elle meurt mais
il a complètement
résorbé en assistance à personne en
danger s'il ne fait bien sûr oui il a un
look race ya urgence ils ne savent pas
ce que le schéma faire ils ne savent pas
s'il va les gorges et ils ne savent pas
si elle va mourir
qu'est ce qu'on voulait qu'ils fassent à
part se couvrir la dame ils vont laisser
le chien l'a bouffé et j'ai une question
est juste à guillaume depuis 2016 les
animaux tous les animaux en temps est
une personnalité juridique oui donc
pourquoi dans ces cas là juste les
chiens non mais arrêtez avec vos
suppositions dans l'état s'il avait fait
ça et s'il a déclenché alors là bas tu
attends qu un
sur deux chez
moi ça me fait peur vous alimenter
encore une fois une tension sociale ou
c'est tout noir il en détient il décrit
un peu d'excitation
foutu et en réponse
on est pas dans une promenade classe où
tout d'un coup il ya un chien qui
retourne et là on est avec une première
jeune femme au sol ou seconde jeune
femme des policiers qui interpellent un
monsieur donc là une situation vous
serez dégénère dans plus des trois
points différents et donc évidemment là
et en plus à une jeune femme qui
j'imagine comme elle se fait peur d'être
en train d'hurler ans dont on n'a pas
les assure donc à une panique il est
retiré
c'est horrible mais voilà bière qui est
un ami proche de la famille oui en moi
je voulais rajouter que oui moi je suis
plutôt d'accord avec guillaume est ce
que dit gilles parce que force jeu comme
vous les 10 le chien a déjà attaqué cinq
minutes avant et on a réussi à lens et à
chiens dangereux oui je suis d'accord
monsieur pernikoff par exemple vous avez
dit que votre chien s'est échappé
imaginez on aurait croisé même s'il
peut-être votre chien d'attaqué personne
mais juste par peur un policier ou autre
l'aurait violentée sais
rien je ne vais pas le garder mon chien
c'est ce qui me fait de la peine je ne
vais pas pouvoir le garder parce que
c'est un chien incontrôlable et qu'il
faut vraiment qu'ils soient élevé avec
amour et un peu de temps c'est un chien
très très sexy 1 là en l'occurrence il
comme tous les chiens
et elle a raison j'ai fait une connerie
la wii fait une connerie et elle a
raison et c'est important que les gens
l'entendent j'ai fait une connerie c'est
un chien qui demande énormément
d'attention pour comme beaucoup de
chiens et en l'occurrence celui là vous
le savez il est attaché à son maître et
il a besoin qu'on s'occupe de lui au
total ce que je voulais juste vous
répondre là dessus c'est qu'il a attaqué
un autre chien et il l'attaqué en
faisant tomber la propriétaire du chien
sur lui donc c'est une puissance très
important maintenant ce que je voulais
c'est le nom le sang du canton streicher
et maintenant ils auraient pu lui tirer
dessus sera était de ma faute parce que
le chien et s'est échappé de chez moi
mais j'aurais vécu avec ça j'aurai des
tristes mais j'aurais aimé césaire il ya
guillaume ier renversé a dit guillaume
hier qui lie la ville un enfant vaut
celle d'un chien delphine vous étiez
très ému ni quelle votre action
aujourd'hui à un peu plus voilà oui j'ai
bien j'ai bien dormi dessus je remercie
toutes les personnes qui m'ont envoyé
des messages parce que je pense que j'ai
je suis pas seul à penser voilà à penser
ça et je le répète nicolas j't'adore
mais effectivement quand on prend un
chien quelques ballons alors alors alors
là oui je vous le redis et c'est pas 30
millions d'amis ici de césium
les chiffres sur la norme on n'est pas
sur animaux tv voilà dix ans fois dire
des poncifs sur les animaux quand on
prend un animal aulnoye occupés on doit
l'aimer et on doit bien s'en occuper on
n'a pas besoin de ça les français
non mais si si la bourgeoisie la
majorité les français font pas du tout
et sur une identification
le chien aurait commencé on aurait
retrouvé le propriétaire julien doré
mais ça change ça ils s'en
moquent c'est aussi pour ça on doit
donner des croquettes aux chiens et aux
douaniers de merde dollars et on doit
les besoins
ce que je veux dire c'est que ce chien a
mordu une personne ou deux personnes il
se fait tuer cette balle alors que il ya
plein de gens qui maltraitent qui font
des sévices aux animaux ils prennent
même pas d'amendé ou même quand
on est d'accord le sujet c'est un autre
débat je dis juste ce que guillaume
voulait dire et c'est vrai que ça peut
paraître maladroit moi il ya dix ans
j'ai aussi eu un buzz chez ruquier parce
que je disais un peu la même chose vous
aviez dit quoi en fait c'était c'était
une affaire où un mec avait mis un
chaton dans une machine à laver tout ça
il ya dix ans et on m'avait demandé de
réagir dessus on m'avait demandé de
réagir de crg dit ben en fait c'est
hyper important que les services sociaux
se concentre non mais à vrai dire dessus
le mec est complètement con
et donc j'avais dit j'avais dix gouttes
est important que ces services sociaux
et de la protection de l'enfance aille
danser girola parce que là où il ya des
maltraitances d'animaux il y a aussi des
maltraitances d'enfants et on m'a dit
mais comment ça on a droit de maltraiter
des animaux sans forcément maltraiter
les enfants tu compare les deux et tout
ça c'est en ça que je dis il faut
respecter tout le monde en fait les
animaux ne sont pas inférieures à six
bons et qu'ils étaient bons j'ai juste
une question pour delphine il ya deux
ans il y à là il ya eu la sphère elisa
pilarsky cette femme qui a été dévoré
par son break mon chien qui était une
petite boule elle était enceinte et donc
j'aurai juste une caisse et sa faute
alors voilà est-ce que sk à ce qu'à la
place de la police tue le tannat dit le
chien bien sûr merci merci mais tu sais
pas pour quel avion chilien mais
puisqu'elle mettait son chien
je
voulais juste atteindre reconnaît
dont vous savez pourquoi vous êtes d
égoïste parce que vous ne lisez la
situation que de votre point de vue oui
que vous pensez que votre petite
personne c'est à dire qu'en fait je mets
à la place de quelqu'un qui s'est fait
mordre par un chien ok qu'est ce qui lui
arrive à la jeune femme mais lakhouad et
des cicatrices des blessures et elle
même est très triste que le chien voilà
alors furent donc donc je suis me faire
lentement par un chien c'est pas bien du
tout g 3g trois cicatrices c'est très
mal etc mais la vie elle continue ça
dans un an dans deux ans il sera en vie
de la vie du chien s'est terminée et
le chien
robin qui n'a pas de muselière il peut
peut-être être mis dans un milieu plus
rural avec un enclos une fera de mal à
personne il ne faut pas de tuer autant
rien et vous estimez que valeria valérie
savait pas guillaume la section analyse
à froid oui après coup mais elle est là
quand les policières ils ne savent pas
où le chien exactement mort s'il atteint
une artère qui peut être cet
enseignement mortelle pour la jeune
fille parce qu'elle est donc dans le
dans le doute il dans le doute on le tue
moi pardonnez moi mais je me sens
complètement étrangère à ce has à ce
débat parce que effectivement je pense
qu'il faut effectivement traiter les
animaux avec beaucoup de bienveillance
bien sûr d'amour me donnerait on est
tous d'accord sur tout mais moi au
niveau des droits des animaux par
rapport aux droits de l'homme pardon je
mettrais toujours les humains au dessus
des animaux pour moi ça n'est pas pareil
pour moi voilà au niveau de la
civilisation au niveau de l'art au
niveau du progrès l'homme est au dessus
d'un animal peu de masques à ce moment
là on les animaux dans le cas des
dollars par là vous mélangez tout haut
niveau dans demande pas aux animaux
d'avoir le droit de vote ni le permis de
conduire
même par les libs avons dit non ce que
je veux dire c'est que quand par exemple
là on parle d'un chien mais si par
exemple comme le disait très justement
tout à l'heure béatrice si par exemple
il ya un crocodile qui attrapent votre
jambe est ce que vous allez faire aussi
la russie regarde lacoste
alors quand même le crocodile oui le
droit de l'animal comme comment vous
gagnez un jalon il ya des chefs ont
cartonné ralph lauren toujours pour moi
toujours l'homme mortiers de l'animal
qu'il advienne et toujours dire traiter
les animaux voilà c'est vrai je pense
qu'il convient de rappeler c'est hyper
important de considérer le contexte et
de pas répondre de façon arbitraire et
aussi facilement à une question pareille
puisque la personne qui était là sur
place qui connaît la victime est à un
avis extrêmement
passive ou le chien qu'il a été donc
donné à cette jeune fille et vous dites
on connaît pas le propriétaire donc en
fait le chien est une donnée par qui
demain on sait ça que je dis j'ai déjà
le propriétaire apparemment veut s'en
débarrasser
s'cusez moi personnellement je le
connais pas
[Musique]